AUDIENCE: I wanted to give
an answer to 2.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So to both parts--
like, one of the parts
was, like, how do the discourse
of power affect the role.
Like, I don't know, how
do discourse of powers
affect how I choose
to, I guess, identify
or how I choose to make
decisions related to language.
For example, I'm from
Mexico and I speak Spanish,
but at the same time, part
of wanting to be more Mexican
is acknowledging that we
have native languages.
Like, Spanish is a language
that was imposed on Mexico--
people who were from
the land of Mexico.
And it sounds like, because
I want to, I don't know,
get to know that
part of Mexico,
that motivates me
to try to learn
some of the native
languages like [INAUDIBLE]..
Or just because I feel
it's like I could be more--
RACHEL: More Mexican?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, more Mexican.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'd even
add that in these discourses
of power, how they affect
how we see our roles
and my choice of identity,
I think that really explains
why a lot of
African-Americans see
African-American vernacular
English as something bad.
It's something that we keep
private a couple times.
I have been caught and
chastised for letting
it slip out in public.
Like, you know, going out to
eat with family members to get--
and so, you know, oh, don't
talk like that in public.
And I think this question
speaks to the heart of that.
AUDIENCE: And for the
first part, I wanted to--
like, we were talking about
authenticity and language,
but something I
want to comment--
it's something like
I feel like speaking
a language is an
experience, but just
by the fact that it
has different stories,
and different sayings,
and all this stuff.
So in some sense, not
speaking a language, you're--
for example, I'm sure
there's a lot of sayings
in Creole or in Chinese
that I will never
be aware of, because I
don't speak the language.
And it's almost like I'm
not experiencing them.
That doesn't mean
I'm less authentic,
but it just really
means that like if you--
like, I cannot
identify as Chinese,
because I haven't had
those experiences.
It's not to say that that should
change how people identify,
but like, what I [INAUDIBLE]
say is like there is--
we cannot ignore the role
that language does have
and experience do have
in, I don't know--
for example, somebody who is
Mexican American, even then I
don't think being
American, it's almost like
deprives you from Mexicano.
Even some of the most
famous Mexican people
like artists, like,
artists like Selena.
Selena, like she's not
from-- she was from Texas,
but everybody, my grandma,
everybody loves her.
And I think it's
part of just like
how much of the quote, unquote
like "collective experience"
you had.
That being said,
you were mentioning
how language in some
sense is a barrier.
I think parts of being
barrier means that you can--
it's overcome-able.
Like, if I wanted
to experience more--
I don't know.
If I wanted to--
let's say I want to work
in Haiti in the future,
and I want to not
feel like an outsider.
Then part of it is like me--
in that sense, it's hard that
I didn't experience that,
and I have to learn a language.
But it's part of--
just because it's hard to be
two people at the same time--
at the same time, I
think it's possible to--
if I don't know--
the fact that it's a
barrier means that I think
it's possible to-- you know?
I don't know.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: In fact,
you go back to the areas
that you mentioned, the
fact that they were--
the documentary makers
from New York were--
they were Haitians who
grew up in New York,
and they were
concerned with losing--
they didn't speak
Creole, so therefor they
weren't Haitians enough.
But now, in fact, they
reached back to me last week.
Anyway, continue the
interview, because I'm
going to ask another
question, which
is that if you're Haitians who
grew up in the diaspora, OK,
you learned Haitian
Creole, you see?
So what would I suggest, and
what do I see as the advantage
of Haitian diaspora to actually
try to keep the language--
actually, if they haven't--
they didn't grow up speaking
it, how can they learn it now
even if they are adults?
And so, [INAUDIBLE], your point
is that you can always learn.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and it doesn't
make the experience less
in the first place, but
it's just like if you
want to enhance it--
not enhance it, but
it's like if you want
to listen to other people--
if you want to--
there are some other things
that you might experience,
but like it's not the end.
RACHEL: I just
wanted to add sort of
on the basis of language
being an experience.
So the other day, so my
boyfriend is Haitian,
and I'm learning Creole.
This is for the
people who haven't
taken this class the entire
semester, and we were--
so there was a time period--
and you can correct me
if I'm wrong-- where
Haitians stopped--
the Kompa stopped being a
thing for a little bit, which
is like Haitian music, and now
it's becoming more of a thing.
And so, there's a lot of
like young music groups,
and the main way I've been--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So I could use
some feedback about Kompa--
RACHEL: I love Kompa.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: --with
the [INAUDIBLE] Kompa.
RACHEL: I don't know if I
have an American reference.
If you know what
Machata is, it's
like Machata but not really.
It's--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: It's better.
RACHEL: --a partner dance.
I can't agree with that.
I'm very much invested in both.
But there's a lot of
young music groups
that are producing
new Kompa music,
and the way I've been sort of
learning with the absence of,
like, time to sit down
and go through a book
is just by listening
to the songs and, like,
learning the lyrics.
And we went through a song,
and it took us an hour
because there were so many
cultural references that there
was no way without
being Haitian or having
Haitian parents-- like,
there was no way you
would have known what it was.
I can't think of one
off the top of my head,
but in this whole experience
of, like, being here
and learning about
Haitian experience.
Like, there is a restaurant
in Miami called Tap Tap.
I didn't know that
Tap Tap was a bus.
That was an
interesting experience.
It's a bus, an open-back
bus you run and jump onto it
in the middle of traffic.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: So our
colleague was now [INAUDIBLE]..
He said something that
is very beautiful--
that when the language
dies out, it's
like a library
that's burned down,
because a language
is a whole library.
And as you mentioned, it's
a whole set of experiences
that you can only really enter
through the language, and so
the examples of our thinking.
But we can enter it.
You know, we might not master
all the books in the library.
In fact, who can ever read--
if it's a big library,
you cannot read all the books.
In fact, I, myself, I
learn proverbs every day
in Haitian Creole.
It doesn't end.
And sometimes, I
learn about proverbs
through other
cultures, because there
are many proverbs in Haitian
Creole that I've found also
in Africa--
in West Africa, even
in South Africa--
and sometimes the meanings
are slightly different,
and sometimes you'll learn
more about your Haitian proverb
by learning it
through an African.
And then we could say,
oh, that sounds familiar.
And then you understand
better, what the proverb means,
through the African
substrate or ancestry.
I think we should stop
here for the discussion.
Are you guys happy?
Do you have anything else
that you want to add?
Are the two of you--
RACHEL: Jonathan.
AUDIENCE: So you just
mentioned that when
a language that's
out of a library
motel and language
as an experience.
I'd even argue that I would have
applied that same definition
to identity as well.
That's why I was really
glad that I didn't answer
the first question first
[INAUDIBLE] taking a hit,
because-- you know, I was
sitting here reading it,
and I was choked by it, because
[INAUDIBLE] the short answer
to that question.
Because the notion
of authenticity
is really kind of vanity,
and I agree with what Sophie
was saying earlier that we--
there's a tendency to hide
ourselves under these labels,
and we kind of
neglect our own power,
and we in a formation
maintenance,
I guess, of identity--
and kind of like what
she was saying about wanting
to sort of take and grab hold
onto a mutual power to
forge your own identity,
and I think that's really
everybody's responsibility?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Right.
And that reminds me.
Maybe I should bring back
this issue of stereotypes.
And it's a whole new
literature these days
on fixed mindset
versus growth mindset.
So in a way and given
what you just said,
one can think of this notion
of having identity that's fixed
is pretty much like this notion
of having a fixed mindset,
because if you believe in--
and in fact, there
is a lot of research
that show that-- that if you
have a growth mindset meaning
that you could actually learn
new things-- that you're not
bounded by your experience.
You can always go beyond that,
and that requires, of course,
practice.
Because this is
something that's--
intelligence is not innate.
You can always develop
more intelligence.
Now that's a big break
from previous literature.
Previous beliefs
that they were--
you were born with a certain
amount of intelligence.
It's like height, and you
cannot go beyond that.
So the new literature on growth
mindset versus fixed mindset
tells us we can always go
beyond what we are born with,
which means that identity should
not be taken as something which
is given once and for all.
It can always massage it,
given particular context
and given particular needs.
So maybe actually-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's not like
infinitely mutable though--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Sure, of course.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like, your skin
color's kind of fixed,
and that's how
people [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHEL DEGRAFF: But we know--
I don't if you
remember way back when.
[INAUDIBLE] gave an
example of this person
who changed-- who was white
and changed to be black.
What's her name?
She had a job in the ACLU.
AUDIENCE: Rachel Dolezal.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That was you?
That was you who said it?
Yeah, so even that--
even that, because of skin
color doesn't come alone.
It comes with particular
assumptions about skin color.
Like, in Haiti there are
people who look very white
but who are black.
Well, if to go back
to Dessaline to 1805,
isn't really that even
if you are Polish,
you want to be black,
so even back then,
skin color was not determined--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, although
it's interesting,
because with Rachel Dolezal,
I feel like most people are
saying they don't accept
her identifying as black,
so I feel like that supports
the idea that there's something
that's kind of fixed about it.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: But I feel like that
ties into what [INAUDIBLE] is
saying about and what you guys
are all saying about cultural
experiences tying into
certain things-- like,
it being a cultural--
it's not just about how--
like, I guess am I wrong or
right for having this attitude?
Like, kind of don't
feel like she--
not like don't feel like
she should be allowed to,
but I wouldn't
want to accept her
because it's like how
dare you, a person who
has had no experience as
an African-American human
try to identify with that.
And maybe it would have been
different if she had been
a person of color trying
to identify-- like,
if she had been
Indian or, you know,
I'm trying to think of another--
or Filipino or something
trying to identify
as African-American, maybe I
would have been more lenient,
but as a privileged non-person
of color, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: But it's
also interesting,
the idea that when you're
crafting your identity
and crafting your authentic
identity, what do you--
your whole identity,
your authentic identity
is that you're not
authentic to anything,
but when you're
crafting your identity,
what do you draw from?
Is it like what you
authentically feel as,
or is what you
authentically have ties to?
Like, I have a similar
situation where,
like, mixed Indian heritage kind
of thing, and when I'm crafting
my Indian American identity,
do I base it off South Indian,
do I base it off Mauritian,
do I base off of North Indian?
Like, what what do I do?
But it's like, do I
pull from the past
or pull from what I feel?
And Rachel Dolezal's,
her whole thing
was that I feel black,
whatever that means, but like
where do you draw from?
AUDIENCE: And in a similar
way that doesn't just
apply to what you identify
as nationality-wise or
culture-wise, because I've been
so focused on being a linguist
that the possibility
of having a capacity
and having the intuition
to be a mechanical engineer
never occurred to me,
but in participating
with some friends who
are creating projects,
I've been the one who
to come up with ideas
that solved problems.
And I never thought that
would be a possibility for me,
because I don't like math.
So it's like the identity
of being a linguist
was so limiting that I didn't
even know I could do that,
and I think that it's, like,
along the same lines of are
we limiting what we can be
by choosing our identities as
well?
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's a
good question to ponder.
AUDIENCE: And yeah, sorry.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: No, that's good.
That's very good.
I think let's stop
here, and we're now